artificial intelligence ai
by now most of us will have met with
artificial intelligence of some kind
okay sarah what will the weather be like
tonight
i will search what will the leather
be like tonight problem is it doesn't
always come across as
very smart belt buckle in matte
[Music]
pvd
at other times it is a little too smart
one day i say tour fell right
the next i get an advert for visiting
paris
coincidence the reason is the same in
both cases
data too much too little or the wrong
kind
without data there is no ai it's what ai
feeds on
in the eu we want ai to put people first
to servers while respecting our values
so we can trust the technologies around
us that's why we have defined key
requirements to ensure that
humans stay in charge ai systems are
safe
data remains private we know if we're
dealing with a machine
or a living creature ai tools are
accessible to all
they benefit all and they can be
monitored
and checked research in ai in the eu
is backed up by major investments repeat
after me
of weather weather and by offering ai
courses
we want to give the next generation the
opportunity to be smarter
humans and bots alike